we are from a lot of young writers who
much rather break into television rather
than writing for film so what's the best
way for a writer to get started mmm like
I tell all my students that 90% chance
they'll be working in television film is
getting just by way of introduction you
you will see very few people coming out
of graduate school for example even
though they're older and getting their
films made they'll get deals they'll get
you know especially if they come
recommended television is you know as
Peters been saying the market is
changing and growing there's good
there's so many channels everybody wants
to be making you know Netflix is making
shows Google's gonna start making shows
I've heard don't know it'll never happen
American movie classics changed its
whole way of doing it a and E which was
all documentaries I know because I wrote
a lot of them it's now all narrative
there's no more documentaries on A&E
it's all you know it's all so that's the
place to go now how to break in well if
there were one answer to that it would
be easier my experience has been that
it's usually a four to five years to
break in and get any kind of job you can
get in the in the industry that puts you
as close to a writer's room as you can
get I have one student who after five
almost five years is now on a cable show
called long mirror which is the the
biggest hit a Andy has ever had it's
it's her the two show runners and I
think the novelist who the show is based
on his novels is in there you imagine
the education she's kidding it's like
going to grad school and getting paid
for it and no she's not making as much
money as if she were on The Good Wife
but she's gonna get her scripts produced
and before that she was in the writers
room as an assistant of her
notice she worked for Jay Leno on The
Tonight Show for two years as an
assistant and she just did and then all
that time all of us were trying to help
her get a manager so getting a manager
today could be more important than
getting an agent because a management
works much better and a manager of
they're really good we'll find you an
agent it manages in large part of taking
the place of what agents used to do was
just to get you work agents typically
make deals now and and I know a couple
of very seasoned writers or not even
that old who whose agents don't even
tell them when a producer like their
script nobody tells them they had that
Harley Peters had that experience where
he wrote two scripts for Loren Michaels
and was probably paid a great deal of
money to write them and the only person
who called him was his manager oh yeah
they really liked it charlie yeah they
may they may or may not make them but
they really love them and sure because
he's Charlie Peters he got paid a lot of
money but managers I think to try to
find a manager and the way you do that
is contact just the way you've always
done it you contact everybody you know
and you take any kind of job you can get
you